lair is with us in Alabama I Blair
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thanks
Dave
so I guess real quick me and my husband
have 123 thousand dollars in debt
sixty-five thousand of that is charged
off credit cards I've been listening to
the show for a few weeks now and I'm
glad I did because I write some really
good pointers as far as handling these
credit cards we're starting a debt
snowball my question is is as we save
the money up to tackle these credit
cards one by one
and I settle with them what do I need to
worry about as far as the rest being
charged off as like cancelled debt do I
need to worry about as far as taxes if
that's going to be considered income
that I'm gonna have to pay taxes on sure
what to expect that forgiveness is
taxable income you will get a 1099 on
that and so you have a ten thousand
dollar credit card and they agree to
settle it for three they're gonna send
you a 1099 for the seven thousand dollar
difference and that will go on your tax
bill but we'll worry about that later
the tax bill is not a hundred percent so
you but you know that it's gonna create
a couple grand in taxes too so you don't
get out of you don't get out completely
free with that and of course should that
debt snowball should be worked after
your other debts are paid that are
active okay one of the other debts
what's the other sixty thousand um well
forty thousand of its student loans ten
thousand is a home equity loan my car is
about fifty three hundred and there
might be a couple of smaller just
miscellaneous I tell you what sure
what's your household in about seventy
six thousand say if I do get mileage for
work so that doesn't including in my
mileage it sounds like you've been
poking around our material a little bit
you've probably already heard me say
this but when you've got old bad debt I
separate that from active debt and I run
two different debt snowballs the first
one is the act of debt so I'm not
screwing these credit cards right now
under 7:00 p.m. the only thing that
scares me and i--i solutely understand
that is one of my credit cards actually
sent me a civil complaint earlier this
year
and we're going to sue me so we are on a
settlement then - because I didn't want
to have to go to court because honestly
I mean it's embarrassing this is not how
its raised I've never intended to not
pay it but we had fun settle back if
they raise their head up and do
something like that you can settle that
one but but otherwise I want you to
clear up this car loan the student loan
other miscellaneous stuff because that
clears up cash flow for you yeah see
when if you're not paying the credit
cards and you pay one of them off it
doesn't change your monthly budget but
if you pay off your car you know the car
payment anymore changes your monthly
budget by the car payment and enables
you to get after the old credit card
debt faster so unless they raise their
head up and smack you with a suit or
something I just let them sit over there
in the bushes
okay just let them sit there and don't
wake them up I'll let sleeping dogs lie
and then you wake them up after you get
your student loan your car payment and
your active debts cleared
that'll give more room in your budget to
be able to attack the rest of it be sure
you get all of these amounts for these
the old bad debts agreed in writing
before you give them any money and on
old bad debts never give them electronic
access to your checking account they'll
clean you out they lie you can tell
they're lying if their mouth is moving
it's a it's a horrible industry so bad
stuff hey thanks for the call